[Music]
we are breaking into programming to go
live to moscow where russia's president
vladimir putin is speaking let's listen
in
[Music]
[Music]
forgive us we're having problems at the
moment uh getting the english uh
translation uh for you to to hear uh
what president putin is saying in the
last few moments he said that russian
soldiers
are acting bravely as real heroes he
called them he said that
russian soldiers are sacrificing their
lives
citing the success
of the russian army in ukraine he gave
examples of what he says is heroism
uh he's handed out the hero of russia
award
to a foreign soldier he's proud he says
to be part of
the multinational people
of uh russia
he says that ukrainians and russians are
one people now we've got the translation
let's listen
[Music]
on the railway stations in kharkov
we have
[Music]
about 3 000
students including those of indian
nationalities
others in sumi the neo-nazis
have opened fire on the chinese students
who were attempting to leave the kharkov
city
other
civilians who are trying to flee the
combat front lines are being fired upon
by the new nazis they are using them as
human shields
the russian armed forces
have opened humanitarian corridors in
all directions allowing
the foreign students and innocent
citizens to leave i repeat once again
the neo-nazis
are not allowing them to pass
in addition
they are opening fire on them
and
using them as human seeds
they are even
calling on their
those people to call upon their
diplomatic commissions
[Music]
some of the residents
go down the lower stories while they
install
machine guns and cannons
on the upper floors
these are the acts of the
nazis once again i repeat the russians
military men
are doing all what they can
to protect innocent civilians
unfortunately
some are falling victims
we are lending all assistance possible
to the families
of those who have fallen defending our
home
our people
[Music]
amounting to seven million rupees in
addition to monthly
payments
additional payments will be provisioned
to
and all the injured
will have similar financial provisions
military men is put to retirement
they will have
a two-point million rupal reward
all these provisions have been made
and the necessary funds
are made available it is also
necessary
to commit other provisions
amounting to three
million rupees for each and every
soldier taking part in the combat
operations
as we speak
our
military men are defending our homeland
doing all what they can
to eradicate the neonate
in our people we will always remember
our fallen
comrades who have fallen
in the line of action we will
do
all the necessary
including
committing financial provisions to their
families now we will stand
to honor
the fallen who have fallen in the
military combat
in donbass
[Music]
the military plan is going as planned
according to the time set and all the
targets are being hit successfully the
defense minister will provide the
technical details in his report
all right that was russia's president uh
vladimir putin
uh speaking we're not sure whether that
was uh live or whether it had been
recorded earlier
but he said that russian soldiers are
acting bravely as real heroes soldiers
he said are sacrificing their lives
uh russians and ukrainians are one
people he said he's proud to be part of
the multinational people of russia his
soldiers are doing all they can to
protect any innocent civilians he said
ukrainian forces have taken thousands of
foreign citizens hostage including
students
he says his servicemen have provided
humanitarian corridors for civilians to
flee those corridors are being blocked
by ukrainian nationalists he says that
ukrainian forces
are using civilians as human shields uh
he's uh speaking to his uh
national security uh council now let's
bring in al jazeera's dawson jabari who
was listening to that as well she's in
moscow dawson what did you make of that
well i think it's clear he wants to
deliver a strong message a united front
to the russian public this is a
meeting that was broadcast
after it took place earlier today and it
was not live and this was an emergency
session of the security council which is
made up of high-ranking officials 30 of
them and
the president then made the statements
uh really trying to convince the
russian population that things are
absolutely going according to plan
reiterating that narrative that they are
fighting
a good fight in ukraine and they are
doing it for the security of their own
country i think the main point was that
he did
announce that there would be financial
compensation for the soldiers that have
lost their lives and also those that
have been wounded
during this uh invasion and he said that
he was
thanking the soldiers and their families
for their bravery i think this is very
much a
vladimir putin that he wants to portray
a strong
military campaign that they've launched
in ukraine and that one that is going
according to plan despite what the west
is accusing it of being in complete
tatters and various reports from the
european uh countries saying that there
are problems within the russian military
this is the commander-in-chief himself
saying that is not the case and we are
really succeeding and things are
recording going according to plan
uh
this uh happening as um
um
negotiations are underway those talks
between uh ukrainian officials and
russian officials uh just over the
border from ukraine in in belarus what
are the the
the hopes for those those talks also
well there aren't
very
big hopes really i think the uh russian
president spoke to the french president
emmanuel macron just a short while ago
the two men had a 90-minute phone
conversation
the call was at the request of the
russian president and uh coming out of
that there had to there was very
different reads and takes from the
kremlin we heard that the phone call
went well and that the two men discussed
their
ongoing operation as the russians call
it in ukraine and vladimir putin
explained to emmanuel macron what was
happening and what was taking place and
also that that their operation in
ukraine will continue until the end and
the end for him
is a ukraine that is demilitarized that
is neutral that doesn't have any
offensive weapons that doesn't have
any nuclear um program that that could
pose a threat to russia the elysee
palace issued a statement was very
different and very concerned about the
tone that was coming from the russian
president emmanuel macron said he fears
that the worst is yet to come and
according to sources from the eliza
palace
that the russian president was really
not going to stop until he took all of
ukraine the french president also said
that there was nothing in what putin
said that could
reassure us
and um he told me vladimir putin that
you are lying to yourself and that it
will cost your country dearly and that
your country will end up isolated
weakened and under sanctions for a very
long time and this is a leader of the
french president who usually likes to
point out the positives and clearly the
conversation that he had with vladimir
putin at this point was not a positive
one still those talks are ongoing as we
speak three ukrainian members from the
kiev government are sitting across six
russian representatives near the border
between belarus and poland discussing
what each side would like to see happen
the russians want the ukrainian military
to lay down their arms and the ukrainian
officials want a ceasefire and a
humanitarian corridor to be established
as quickly as possible whether or not
any of that will happen it's very
unlikely but
the important point now is that the two
sides are still talking
al jazeera's torso jabari reporting live
from moscow many thanks indeed so let's
bring it out to zero as andrew simmons
then he's in levith
uh in western ukraine near the border
with uh poland andrew let's pick apart
for a moment uh what we heard uh
president putin saying that russia's
military advance in ukraine is going to
plan
he said russians and ukrainians are one
people even if many ukrainians have been
brainwashed ukrainian forces have taken
thousands of foreign citizens hostage
including students he says his
servicemen have provided humanitarian
corridors for civilians of flee
corridors which are being blocked by
ukrainian nationalists ukrainian forces
he said are using civilians as human
shields is there any evidence for any of
that
there doesn't appear to be any evidence
and it's the first most people have
heard of this
it does seem to have come from nowhere
uh it is a serious allegation obviously
and i'm sure there'll be some response
and as dorsa was
was pointing out there is a a pretty
dark backdrop
to
the talks that are ongoing as far as
we're aware between the russian
delegation and the ukrainian delegation
now add to the pessimism coming from the
french president uh there is pessimism
coming from the ukrainian president
zielinski in that he feels that he needs
the help of europe more help from europe
more help from the rest of the world for
the critical situation his country's in
it's fighting for its very survival he
outlined that in a news conference he
was appearing pretty much
the most aggressive
uh he's been since this conflict began
we're in our second week of the invasion
now
and he really really did not refer to
the talks uh at all um the last
the last round of the talks was on
monday uh there appeared to be no
real advance in
in any making
any any decision making uh but they were
still talking
and at that point the president here
president zielinski did say that they
were listening to russia
but now
it would appear
with so much
negative ground having mounted up since
then with the invasion going into its
second week and into a phase whereby the
russian advances the russian attacks on
civilian areas according to the
ukrainians and what is seems to be
on the ground an investigation in in all
directions including the international
criminal court
there is
very very little in the way of common
ground between the two sides the the
biggest hope of all that ukraine has is
that there are humanitarian corridors
formed
not for the sort of purpose that
the president putin was was suggesting
but for the purpose of getting the
injured civilians the injured out of
this country and aid into this country
that is what that that is what president
zlensky wants and he's in a pretty
desperate position it would seem even
though his his fighters are are doing
incredibly well in many areas but as he
said
thousands of them are dying
and what's the latest andrew on the
humanitarian situation there in
the various cities of ukraine which
are under attack
well i'm looking here at just so many
reports coming in uh
in hersen of course this is the first
city in ukraine to fall to the russians
there are no reports of any further
fighting but it's understood that the
ukrainian forces have withdrawn and
there is an intent on counter-attacks
all over the country where losses have
been made but no further word from there
and chernoheave in the north
just near the border with belarus
there has been a number of attacks a
diesel plant
is on fire and there's been air strikes
on
reportedly two schools
we're hearing now from the emergency
service there
that 22 civilians have been
killed
in the attacks and there are
rescue workers are searching for more
bodies and and trying to rescue people
from the rubble um elsewhere in haki the
situation is absolutely critical um one
official in the presidential office has
described it as a 21st century
stalingrad uh that city
and then we have
uh in the
in the port of mariopol uh which which
is in uh the sea of azeroth the sea of
azov port
massive siege there uh people just
cannot break out and they're they've run
out of all supplies food water uh and
fuel uh critical situation uh appeals
for
a host of
areas of help particularly medical help
because the hospitals
are in a critical state unable to treat
people properly this is a real emergency
of a profound sort um in the capital
heave
there have been further attacks but
there it's just a
an eerie weight for what people feel is
inevitable and that's the push from so
much in the way of armoured columns uh
to come into the city uh there were four
explosions uh uh 12 hours ago sorry 18
hours ago but
there we don't know about the number of
injuries but certainly were very loud
loud explosions overnight and overall
the situation
uh in ukraine right now
is incredibly gloomy
i'll just hear us andrew simmons
reporting from levitt in western ukraine
andrew many thanks indeed